let's say you've written a screenplay
and you feel that
it's a 9 out of 10. it's almost there
how would you get it to be a 10 i don't
think you ever can
at least not in your eyes i've never
done anything that i've said this is a
10 out of 10.
there's always things that i see room
for
improvement um is that a bad answer
no no that's good i think some people
are hardwired that way like nothing
is ever they've got to always tweak
things and i think that makes
people great at whatever they do i
think you were talking about that lately
you have to be somewhat ocd
i think um but yeah i mean i i don't
even think i've ever done anything
that's
nine out of ten i think uh i think
it's this one giant journey to sort of
you know make that 10 out of 10 project
and i think that's what gives me hope is
this constant
evolution of wanting to be better and
wanting to make your next project
even more perfect than the last one but
every time i make one i do look at it
and i say to myself that is
significantly better than the last one
at least more often than not so i see
growth and that's that's really all i
can ask for
i've never actually finished something
and been like 10 out of 10.
have you seen other people's work that
you're like
9 out of 10 10 out of 10. i've seen
other people's work that makes me want
to quit the film industry because i
don't think i'll ever live up to it
um uh i mean i remember seeing
inception in theaters and just
walking out of the theater and turning
to my friend and saying like i don't
even
know if i want to like live in l.a
anymore and make movies because i'm
never going to make something like that
uh it is just that that to me is just
such a wonderful brilliant movie
um so
so yes i i martin mcdonough is another
of my favorites
with like screenwriting-wise i just the
dialogue that he writes
i i aspire to write like that
or or just you know think on that level
um but there's certainly a lot of people
that i i look up to that i think
i don't know if i can ever be that good
so does that make you then want to stop
or make you want to rise
to their level i know that sounds so
cliche sorry i mean i i say that sort of
facetiously i i will
i'll never stop um but but yeah it was
sort of like a funny
funny sarcastic joke you know and i said
that in the movie theater walking out of
inception
i'll never want to stop but it's uh
it's this sort of abstract goal to sort
of
make something that you watch and elicit
the same response in yourself
that you had when you watched something
like inception
and i don't know if that will ever
happen i think i'm always going to be my
harshest critic
but it's definitely something i aspire
to do and it's
what keeps me going is just that sort of
nugget of hope
well a lot of times something that
inspires people is seeing bad work
or even in entrepreneurs they see some
idea and they go i could do better than
that and why does that person get to do
that
i want to do it and there you go and
there's there's the trajectory of their
career because it was all built on
seeing somebody else do something that
they think they failed at
i think that i think that's human to to
look at someone else's work
and and say oh i'm i'm better than that
or or i can i can do that why aren't i
you know why haven't i made it big yet
i i sort of i and i do that on some
level
more so from a business perspective
because i want to be able to make movies
and
you know have have a career and actually
support myself doing that
so i asked myself well why are they
getting paid all of this money to do
something i know i have the skill set to
do
um so i don't really i don't really
think in that way
creatively as much because you know
the story that you choose to tell the
movie that you make is
oftentimes a personal choice and and
who's to say one is better than the
other i think what you can judge is sort
of the
uh you know the the technicals of it the
maybe the business of it you know why is
their movie picked up by
lions gate and distributed worldwide
when mine had all the same
shot on the same camera and you know has
just as much
character growth and 3x structure
format and all of that
do you think it's good to have a little
bit of a a chip on the shoulder in terms
of
having a competitor or or does that not
fuel you i think some people it really
fuels them
i think and others it doesn't i know i
know
it fuels some people i know victoria has
said that it certainly helps to have
have that i don't want to say chip on
your shoulder but
you know that kind of a little bit of
ego
you know like like as though it's a
competition i
i honestly i've never
felt any kind of competition i very much
felt like i've sort of been on my own
journey sort of growing and like i said
before i am my harshest critic
so something really isn't good enough
until
i say it's good enough and it certainly
helps you know going to film festivals
and having people pat you on the back
and say
that was a wonderful movie like great
job and it gives me
a little bit more confidence but even if
they said that was a terrible movie
i would probably still move along and
you know make another project regardless
but it certainly helps
you